boa noite a todos
a salgueiro um senhor que te tu e vai
contar a história de um edifício
os edifícios com mais pessoas de uma
forma metafórica nascem vivem e morrem
de pois é difícil tem a oportunidade de
suscitar
é o caso do edifício que eu vou mostrar
hoje há uma frase por trás de um grande
homem há sempre uma grande lei e eu
adicionei uma etapa anterior e portanto
eu acho que atrás do edifício há um
grande homem e neste caso o homem que
está por trás do edifício vou falar em
equipamento médico foi um energético
empresário no fim do século 19
o brasil voltou a portugal comprou
terrenos entre os nomes e criou aqui é
conhecida hoje como a quinta do meu ao
mesmo tempo e chique que na altura
estava à venda por parcelas ea comprou
duas parcelas do convento monchique
[Música]
viveu morreu mas não teve hipóteses
suscitar a companhia quer a empresa
documento neste tinha duas dificuldades
os principais benefícios do convento
monchique uma prende se com um
o mau tempo que se fazia sentir na barra
do douro e quem teria muitas vezes os
seus barcos e saírem houve entrarem
porque eu fazia prestação de mim pro
brasil áfrica do sul e índia etc e outra
ficou aprendidas com as taxas aduaneiras
que eu tinha que pagar por isto você
precisa mesmo tempo a barra do douro
por volta da mesma altura estava a ser
construído o
porto leixões há precisamente para
suprimir essa dificuldade grande que
existia dos bairros vai passar em valor
em certas alturas do ano quando foi
construído o porto leixões
simultaneamente um engenheiro chamado
henrique magalhães projetou fez o
primeiro plano urbanístico martins que
previa na zona de 60 porto leixões
princípio como praga
temos aqui duas imagens de miguel onde
os povos ver esses bravos que vive na
condição de um material importante mas a
maioria ao do prado fez um plano
urbanístico com uma maior do jornal
curiosamente união quarteirões com as
mesmas dimensões quarteirões de nova
york e nova york até mesmo do outro lado
do oceano
mas é também isso foi realizado e os
quarteirões existem lá portanto quem não
tiver verdadeira nova york onde passaram
a exibir sul que vai ter mais ou menos a
mesma sensação especial
o documento - então os termas em
bagagens parâmetros vinhos e foi um dos
primeiros empresários a construir os
seus armazéns
nesse novo plano urbanístico que se
desenhava o engenheiro henrique méxico
nesta imagem podemos ver já a avenida
que unia e as quais nos quarteirões
vemos a real vinícola construída e vai
de esquerda casa quer casa do
administrador
conseguimos ver ainda um comboio na rua
que era um comboio que ligava o porto
leixões que transportava o vinho
nesta imagem da altura vemos ainda os
funcionários da empresa lado direito a
trazer o edifício legal depósito sites
o edifício maio era o edifício
administrativo eo edifício do lado
esquerdo um grande edifício das armações
vinho
nesta imagem vemos um edifício que era
no lado oposto edifício irmãozinho que
na teoria onde eram fabricados os barris
de vinho já na altura com o sistema
o técnico penso que vá porque ele é
considerado muito vejo esta imagem é do
edifício central do armazém no piso
superior
o armazenamento de barris e do piso
inferior e também de armazenamento este
com uma estrutura mental e quer
precipitar a lavagem do piso superior
estava muito carregada com tantas pipas
ao lado deste desse difícil dizer mas já
existe um outro que era onde é feito o
engarrafamento do vinho e evocado em
caixotes para depois ser transportado
pelos trocador elétrico até o porto de
leixões
nesta imagem quase uma caricatura na
altura consegue ser mais ou menos
o design do edifício é uma espécie de um
edifício em um com uma entrada principal
os edifícios no lado carros conseguem
ler mas vindos da companhia
o grande benefício principal eram as
armas anj onde estavam os bares no piso
por piso frio
o edifício do fundo eram oficinas o
edifício do outro lado era a teoria ea
carpintaria e não tinha uma cantina após
funcionários em uma sala de máquinas e
os dois edifícios clube a vão entrada
principal é o dinheiro tal propósito do
site e vai virar edifício administrativo
consegue ver a linha do comboio tinha
até o porto leixões claro que a escala
proximidade não é rigorosa e apenas para
ilustrar o efeito zero mas funcionará
até por volta de 1930 e depois por uma
das razões econômicas limita as quais
está a primeira guerra mundial ea crise
que se desentendeu tanto na europa pode
colocar as armações fecharam a fábrica
fechou e ficou abandonada cerca de 80
anos passados 80 anos o aspecto edifício
e este era o meu partido compõe apenas
no principal estava em não estava ainda
razoável mas já anuncie num dos extremos
já não tinha criado também
por essa altura vemos ainda que também
por fora o estado era também muito o que
dizer quando entrávamos não era muito
diferente
apesar de ser uma ruína é muito bonita é
que jonas tem sempre uma coisa muito
própria era um espaço que ao mesmo tempo
fazia apenas neste estado de degradação
vemos o edifício principal dos armazéns
em que o princípio já não tem já não têm
cultura eo edifício embuçados empilhado
é o edifício onde o vinho engarrafado
esta imagem entrou nesse difícil
entretanto durante 80 anos que serão
duas áreas que ganhar não importa que se
consegue ver aqui
esta é uma imagem da zona central da
administração o edifício das armações à
esquerda e uma imagem do interior
posterior desse mesmo edifício
nesta imagem conseguimos ver é na rua
dos barris no piso superior
não estava miserável quase ia no piso
inferior que foi onde construíram pois
umas estas paredes divisórias por
incrível que pareça ele foram feitas
para funcionar uma escola durante o ano
letivo entre o edifício dessas escolas
tv em obras então o carro aqui os alunos
não é ter aulas o que parece quase
surreal
entretanto no fim no fim dos anos 90 é a
câmara municipal tomou posse deste
edifício e e há cerca de cinco anos
atrás de uma iniciativa de ser o autor
do projeto e o programa que propunha e
se propôs foi a instalação na casa da
arquitetura das instalações da orquestra
jazz de matosinhos numa zona é
concessionar a privados para lojas e
comércio ir ao espaço o motivo
é caso da arquitetura estamos em todo
este este edifício inferior aqui na
planta
o eta já zezinho está localizada no
edifício do lado direito jonas as lojas
e comércios no edifício o topo superior
e na zona da entrada principal que esta
no lado direito também eo edifício da
casa tentou então as lojas da esquerda
seria um espaço para continuar os dois
edifícios do maio originalmente um
depósito de entrada e de saída passariam
a ser um história e um espaço multiusos
a obra começou começaram os trabalhos de
infra estruturas tentou integrar toda a
infra estruturas por baixo do pavimento
forma que não fosse perceptível
os novos espaços foram transformados em
em caixas e não em paredes que era para
tentar que essa leitura o campo visual
primeira vez e se não fosse interrompida
porque ver esta nave novo piso superior
e talvez o passo mais difícil
no piso superior composto telhado que
estava em falta com um no fundo usando
novas tecnologias mantendo o design
original das peças nas áreas da
estrutura e amazonas podem ler é a
transição do novo pronto o antigo para o
novo e foi isto foi a vão também
quisemos deixar visível porque achamos
que fazer sentir e perceber o edifício
ao longo do tempo as marcas das
intervenções que fossem feitas ao longo
do tempo no edifício
esta imagem é do edifício originalmente
originalmente era engarrafado vinho e
encaixotado e que agora tem como novas
funções a zona de conservação e restauro
documentos que venham a ser arquivados
na casa da arquitetura tem como maquetes
o design pode se ver a nova estrutura do
telhado
com design exatamente igual ao desenho
original dessa nessa estrutura e as duas
áreas que cresceu entretanto e que se
optou por manter criando dois patos de
hoje tamanho do lado da empresa na
enchente onde vão ser criados espaços
das lojas e comércio que era uma parelha
fechadas em uma janela houve necessidade
de criar aberturas para ver se haverá um
diálogo entre a rua e os espaços
comerciais e então essas janelas
criadilha acesso às janelas também de
uma forma diferente as janelas originais
essa janela são como se fossem umas
molduras que estão encostados à parede
proposição assinar os originais que são
buracos nessa próprio aparelho também
para se perceber que é uma intervenção
contemporânea e que não faz parte do
edifício original
entretanto a obra termina eo edifício
uma cara lavada na zona de entrada com
processos de trabalho do ferro forjado
vizinhança que o arco que era um
argumento original que já não existia
como candidato de peso
já no interior do pátio conseguimos ver
um painel das ruas original à direita
que foi retirado depois voltou a colocar
vemos o primeiro pacto criado para se
deixar ficar harvick tanto no objetivo e
um elemento então em um foi obrigatório
é desenhar o que tem a ver com é uma
caixa de escadas tem a ver com a
segurança contra incêndio e tentar
desenhar uma forma mais abstrata e com
as esculturas rica informa que esse
aumento não fosse confundível com o
edifício original e que ao mesmo tempo
que marcasse também um lado
contemporâneo da intervenção
uma outra imagem que se vê um outro
momento também uma caixa de escadas no
lado oposto difícil consegue se ver ao
fundo segundo pátria
nesta vez atrás
o edifício dos antigos armazéns agora o
caso da arquitetura e aqui à frente à
zona de conservação e restauro foi a
pouco e o som do pátio da imagem vemos
ao centro o edifício multiusos que é o
que está mais próximo do edifício
original porque no fundo só se ocupa o
edifício manter sua estrutura e telhado
e e achou-se difícil saber como eu era
originalmente lado esquerdo a zona das
lojas e comércio é privado e voar direto
edifício da casa arquitetura
nesta imagem é esta imagem é o bis
superior dos antigos armazéns que agora
os passos positivos na casa arquitetura
que tem uma área expositiva com cerca de
800 metros quadrados e no piso inferior
por baixo das naves positiva continua a
ter um armazém desta vez mas ainda
arquitetura e não de vinho é uma casa de
arquitetura agora as maquetes desenhos e
documentos texto fotografias tudo ainda
no piso desses arquivos
conseguimos ler que 13 4 são caixas
metálicas são zonas da questão em caixas
metálicas e os espaços trabalhos são
essas caixas nas áreas onde temos um
gabinete de trabalho uma imagem interior
da caixa de escadas dão como sacar e uma
imagem da loja situa originalmente era
zona administrativa da companhia é uma
zona com outro tipo de ferramentas com
mais mas aéreas mais trabalhar os
conteúdos trabalhados e que hoje está
mais sendo lojas 11 caráter também mais
rico em termos materiais e
inclusivamente no design do mobiliário
também faz parte do projeto
entretanto ao longo de todo o processo
sendo uma casa de arquitetura um projeto
midiático - uma das arquitetas tive a
oportunidade de ir conhecendo pessoas
que me diziam muito como por exemplo o
teto paulo mendes da rocha que é um
prêmio
pritzker de arquitetura que brasileiro
tive momentos fantásticos com vai ficar
aos que que é o grande fotógrafo da
arquitetura portuguesa ou pelo menos o
primeiro e na altura da elaboração
encontrei o arquiteto antoni méxico é um
descendente documento nem se estava
visivelmente satisfeito com com a
inauguração em que o resultado como tu
tinha acabado em termos da recuperação
do edifício começou a mim ainda mais
satisfeito
tive com família e amigos visitas
guiadas
sinto que a minha comunicação social
inexplicavelmente e da inauguração e ou
cerca de 12 mil pessoas que apareceram
no fim de semana na real vinícola
aconteceu catorze inclusivamente coisas
muito estranhas que não consigo depois
numa dessa coisa toda estava lá um dia
com um fotógrafo que é o francês que
chega e não estava ninguém lhe pedir
para tirar uma fotografia assim é um
simbolismo ao potencial do ídolo teen em
ruína e outro homem não vence em 31 e
fotografia na internet
claro que no mesmo dia segue a filosofia
de volta cone
um amigo meu designer fogo na fotografia
que existem mandou me e eu fiquei
realmente pensar
ao mesmo tempo termos simbólicos com o
benefício destes não pode nunca precisa
de ser viver precisa do apoio de uma
unidade nunca pode ser uma pessoa só é
difícil e mais uma vez mais tarde voltei
lá para fazer outra visita guiada com os
meus colegas tinham visto fotografias na
internet então tentou se conter uma
fotografia debaixo do edifício e esta se
fartou de sentir porque só é preciso ter
esse tipo de suporte e apoio para um
edifício de sobreviverem suscitar e
continuar a viver
e para terminar com esta frase do
estudantil é curiosamente acho que os
meus testes de arquitetura são escritos
por não architects e e uma vez voltamos
a dar forma ao edifício da real vinícola
o próximo passo dos prêmios que sair
agora real vinícola é formada das
pessoas pela paz em deus de hoje
no futuro também está abrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]